sir bah and further in schedule I really
had a little bit of time we're kind of
this beginning spot where we're taking
to unit and extension one integration
and just kind of widening the envelope a
little bit okay
so the kinds of things we hope that our
identities that involve sorry integrals
that involve trig identities regular
trig identities such as what I've done
is going to use double angle yeah it's
got a name it's got a name the
Pythagorean identity and all that's all
its values so you can use those in a
whole variety of contexts in chin
extension one you'll often be given a
clue in our context you should be able
to work out which one it is
what did we do after just a regular trig
it's yours what's after treating at
University right so we've been doing it
very recently so I didn't do it
background without in detail but I
showed some of my trickier substitutions
that you could do when you train with it
industry yesterday I introduced
introduce i refresh your memory on what
right and I show there was some
algebraic sheets you can do two things
like this 0 say look what I have over
here
I can't work with it but if I massage it
algebraically I can get it into a format
for so long now we're going to continue
on that today but we need this piece so
partial fractions we looked at under
polynomials let's review this right
this guy here if I just think about it
as an integration problem is um it
causes me issues wondering why can't I
just watch it to this as a standard home
why would I need
okay so if I have a quadratic yeah right
I can treat that as my entry that is it
turned into a teeny abyss right now
interestingly I can't go in that
direction but there's an alternative
puff that I can take if I can take this
quadratic denominator it's separated out
into two fractions both with media
denominators can I can deal with it as a
log okay so let's do that
we're gonna need and you can do this
over on the right hand side first so
they say let to on this spectrum you
write let it equal to now can we
remember highest partial fractions work
what are we going to use on the
right-hand side
hey the first factor right plus B on the
other factor okay just what might look
at this have just written this down
suppose this was not X minus 3 suppose
it was x squared minus 3x pretty much
how would that be different over here
yeah I'm gonna have if this denominator
here if my partial fraction ends up with
actually yeah maybe x squared plus 2
because I can't rationalize I can't
factorize that any further in the real
domain if it was X square plus 3 what I
want up here the a and the B they really
stand for the remainder after you've
designed it through and of course a
quadratic divisor will have a linear
remainder but in this case it's all kind
of nice to linear divisors therefore two
constant it means okay so now what do I
do with that we're going to go yeah I
want to combine these because if I get
the denominators the same then I can
compare the coefficients on the
numerators okay so this is how it's
looking
I've got that I'll write the original
fraction one last time and then I can
say look my denominators are now I don't
have to worry about them I can say look
that equals two and then have a choice
I can either evaluate this at choice
values of X like leave it in its
factored Icefall
and then for instance what values my to
choose effects once I once I've canceled
these what values manager I could choose
one right that'll leave me with this guy
and then I choose three which will leave
me with this guy right so either of
those will work you've got that
alternative or the other way which we've
seen before which is to simply compare
coefficients yeah so what stab it now
I'm going to make out of this if i
comparing fishers
what state am I gonna make okay
so I've got these two guys the X terms
which correspond to the 0x verbally so
we'll say a plus B equals zero and so
I'm gonna go ahead and solve can you
just go ahead and solve that full
plus minus one hey which ones which okay
excellent
can we just confirm that that would be
the case by going back and trying that
other method if I said x equals three at
this point what would happen this guy
will disappear so I'm gonna have a times
2 to n which is 2 I'm not gonna bother
completely letting you see how it works
ok excellent now that I've done that I
can say instead of this fraction right I
can write this as the integral of what I
have 1 X minus 3 and I've got minus the
other fraction and so you can see we've
taken something which is kind of like a
key and using these pull it over your
techniques
this is trivial isn't it what am I gonna
get X minus 3 now because I've got two
logs here there's no reason why I can't
simplify this a little bit further and
saying this is actually Lord of